if everybody would just go around just a
sentence about who you are my name is
Debbie I am a little disillusioned with
politics but I am a Democrat and I plan
on voting in the next election
my name is Cynthia I'm an independent
and I'm registered as a Republican my
name is Mary Lou and I will be voting
for a president Trump in 2020 I'm Nellie
Jimenez I'm an independent and I'm not
gonna be voting for Trump
Mary Ellen T Gregorio voted Democrat
before and flipped the switch to Trump
I'm Julia I'm a registered Republican I
voted for President Trump not because he
had the best manners but because he was
the most qualified candidate charelle
I'm a Democrat and I have some
conservative ideals Melinda
I've been a registered Republican for a
long time but I switched to the Democrat
Party last year but I don't like to be
labeled as either a Democrat or a
Republican I'm an American voter how
many of you are still persuadable
listen I'm almost persuadable I do not
vote straight party ticket could there
be a Democrat you could vote for
anything is possible could you vote for
President Trump no no did you vote no
could do it can I vote for a Republican
sure yeah same here
how does everybody feel about politics
right now I still want to participate
but I just don't like the way a lot of
the a lot of the things that are going
on now you feel a little disillusioned
and I just feel I think America can do
better definitely I agree a few I feel
like we had better solutions a good word
or apathy to the max right now because
you know as the older I get you know I
started out young and being involved
Civic wise you know and I said
Republican Democrat didn't make a
difference we all got along because we
were neighbors and it was fun in this
last couple years husband it's like
you're afraid to go out the door just
because I flipped the switch and I'm no
longer primary Democrat I have an
independent thought and I chose another
candidate this time around
I have people that don't even want to
talk to me because I of the choice I
made which i think is really ridiculous
because that's not who I am I'm the same
person I was the day before he got in
office show of hands who thinks the
country is headed in the right direction
what do you like about what's happening
oh I like the fact that you know how my
portfolio looks pretty nice right now I
can make my taxes next year cuz you know
as time goes by you know cost a living
does not match the cost of you know
really living right Julia your hand up
one went up to I would say hands down my
favorite thing that president Trump has
done has been the economy by all
measures I've seen you just blown the
doors off of it
and we all feel that at all levels his
international policy has been bold and
effective in ways that we never
anticipated getting rid of Isis getting
rid of sulamani getting rid of al
Baghdadi I mean bold and everyone was
Chicken Little the sky is falling now
terrible things are gonna happen and
they have not materialized I will tell
you personally I'm a Zionist for a
president to so boldly stand for Israel
is very important to me and I'm a
Christian by the way and finally
national security is critical for me you
can't have your wealth protected you
can't have your international security
without strong borders so I want address
about the border one of the things that
has bothered me is the humanization of
people in the border and how people are
mistreated humanize here so there is a
lot of issues for me there about racial
profiling about also the immigration law
how are you three people who are coming
through the border looking for legally
to enter the border and how they're
being treated and mistreated and put in
jails so for me the issue of the border
is one that I can forget or forgive I
have to agree with you I think that
Donald Trump is allowing people to make
the decision to mistreat people at the
border to have racially charged marches
and all of these things and instead of
having the character integrity to say
because a man has proven to be and again
as a Democrat this is controversial for
me to say is proven to be powerful and
to take a hard stance on something I
like that part of it I do you like that
he's taken hard stance you don't want
some things yes but he's not taking the
hard stance on the racial issues which
are very close to me because I'm a black
female right we need for him to take a
hard line put that hard line in the sand
that he's done with the economy that
he's done with other policies foreign
policies and say hey listen we don't act
like that here what's the issue that
really is going to determine who you
vote for this year I think the economy
is very important and also jobs jobs for
people in the economy but I do think
this current president is really causing
a lot of division amongst people and I
think he's causing a lot of this morning
to me to me is more like a bully
more so than a president it's not a
policy or it's not an issue per se that
that's going to sway me I will vote for
somebody who has demonstrated character
and integrity does anybody else have a
main issue I'm a numbers person so
economic fairness is very important to
me I'm not a Bernie Sanders supporter
I'm not an Elizabeth Warren supporter
but I believe that the Tax Act of 2017
was skewed in favor of the 1/2 of the 1%
and the corporation's who's leaning
Democratic at this point so there's four
of you have you picked a candidate yet
no I have you pick by right now honestly
the lesser of the evils
[Laughter]
point us the process of elimination with
you I could change my mind I could get
in that booth and change my mind right
right now he's got past experience yeah
I think it's that's another thing okay
Melinda and definitely voting for a
Democrat and who can best be Trump how
important is that for for more and more
Democrats here definitely yeah and I do
think Biden's probably at the top of
list but I'm still looking at the other
candidates also character integrity
right now that nobody has so one of my
concerns as an independent is that when
I get into a corner where my choices are
the less evil that's what scares me
about my poor America I'm gonna have to
vote certainly not for Trump but for the
less evil oh the Democratic Party or
whoever else shows up so you're just
you're disappointed in your choice I am
disappointed I don't have choices I
don't I don't feel that I have someone
who's gonna move me I'm originally from
Venezuela and I live through hell
through all of the beginning of what
then became not the dictatorship and
when it came when I started I started as
a socialist and it was so streaming
right and and I don't want to see you my
American could I pick up on something
Nelly said you do have the option to do
a ride in I did a ride in in 2016 at the
presidential level because I couldn't
vote for either the Republican or the
cat or the Democrat running for
president and I know people have taken
issue with me people on the right and
the left my family took issue with me
that I was complicit in Trump's election
but it was a matter of conscience in
this election a lot of us are not voting
just for we're voting for getting Trump
out so if that is really your motivation
then you do have to vote for
or somebody I want somebody I can look
up to somebody has dignity somebody
that's not bullying I don't see Trump is
bullying though I see him challenging
because the ridiculous that goes on
sometimes that he you're right he's not
a politician I thought it was refreshing
to find a businessman who made himself a
millionaire want to work for me that's
what I can't agree with our II don't you
think he's very thin-skinned my
husband's thin-skinned and I
whack-a-doodle and I'm still with them
26 years and I think a politician needs
to be thicker skinned and not excoriate
those who disagree with I won't tell you
there's a long who have failed because
they've taken the high road and they've
been buried by it and I think I'm not
saying that this necessarily appeals to
me but I think Trump appeals to a lot of
people because he punches back so Donald
Trump isn't everyone's cup of tea
without a doubt without a doubt I'm
going to vote for him I don't like
everything he says and I can say that
but what is important to me is as I
approach retirement is am I going to
have a job that is secure will my is my
retirement secure is the market doing
well I don't need him to be like me I
need to be safe and I need to be able to
know that my economy for my friends my
family is solid are you looking forward
to this vote yeah I believe everyone's
hope at this table and in America that
we will have two candidates that will
come together and say we're going to run
a presidential campaign let the best man
win and let's try to have a civil
discourse and social media is a huge
part of this we can live together I
don't mean to sound Pollyannish but we
can live together we can share ideas I
don't have to agree with anybody but I
will always listen to you we would think
we have to look forward to it I mean
reality we can't put our heads in
country let's be involved let's keep our
minds open our hearts open as President
Trump going to be reelected I think you
will be I think you will be you think
you will be